do you feel like
with like now that we've kind of gotten
over the pandemic was there anything
that you were missing as an artist
during that time that is kind of like
kind of adjusted the way you're looking
at the music business because you know a
lot of artists
they they depended on going and getting
bags at the club or the live shows or
you know we heard of a lot of artists
like who were kind of hurting during the
pandemic was there anything that like
you kind of took from the pandemic that
you're able to kind of apply to your
your business model as an artist now
moving forward or anything you learned
I feel like bro I was pushing through
the pandemic super smooth like I don't
know I probably just got more if
anything I got just more uh
detail like I know more about my actual
business like my everything that goes on
it's important yeah I know more about my
ship like than anything like I know
about every part but um I say that's it
because through the pandemic we was we
was good I actually I was decent in a
pandemic bro like I'm because you know
what I'm saying like
I built a brand outside of just being a
rapper so
through that [ __ ] I can like it's like
another just whole thing bro like that's
like a whole different life for me like
I sell hoodies I sell clothes and [ __ ]
like that so that [ __ ] brings a whole
different type of thing to my Revenue in
my whole other Revenue stream yeah so
that's pandemic proof I mean I think
music is pandemic proof this is pandemic
proof but however touring though touring
is not yeah and it was like touring my
favorite part of this [ __ ] touring in
the studio all the [ __ ] in between that
turns into business I hate that [ __ ] I
hate music business I hate the business
I love the fact that you know what I'm
saying I'm able to exist in this [ __ ]
and I've been on for about five six
years now like sign you know I'm saying
I was with Interscope now with Motown
shout out to them but like you know what
I'm saying I I think the business is
kind of it just affects the talent at
all times like for a lot of people I did
a lot of uh I guess the a better way to
answer your question is
um I did a lot of like uh
like purifying myself of the [ __ ]
from the business and cleansing my
[ __ ] mind from that [ __ ] and
like
I think my album turned in a better
Direction because I feel like the album
I was trying to drop like while I was
still in the road like before the
pandemic and [ __ ] was just like all
right because it's been a few years
since we got an album right yeah like
four years that shit's crazy that
[ __ ] just was more so like oh
yeah [ __ ] I'm finna be the biggest like
I felt it like I felt like I felt my
momentum I'm like this [ __ ] finna go
crazy I'm like my next [ __ ] going crazy
so I think I made songs that was gonna
like sound good like to the world
opposed to just like going inward like
let me like try to make my bed so this
is like the album we're gonna get is
kind of like the second iteration of of
an album third the third version of man
this album so it's funny because this
album I'm talking about is all the way
mixed and Mastered by that [ __ ] Ali you
know yeah
I know Ali bro it's mixed and massive
and [ __ ] like we mixed and mastered
another album which is the album that's
coming after this uh love for rent album
and [ __ ] so you already have albums in
the can just ready to go yeah you think
about been doing bro I mean it's been
four years yeah like I've been in the
studio [ __ ] be like you need to ride
to the studio drop the album I'm like
man [ __ ] shut up I've been in the
studio every day like you feel me I
don't where the [ __ ] else I'm gonna go
so this album comes out how much longer
before you drop the other one I ain't so
that that was not on purpose though like
that whole thing like I said I switched
labels you feel me and out a lot of
people like man he's going through labor
[ __ ] hell nah we having our way really
like it's more so just like I was just
trying to be smart and like build a
rapport with the people that I'm gonna
be working with next and I ain't trying
to just be stepping because I've seen
how I wasn't really like able to move
how I wanted to in the last [ __ ] because
you feel me if everybody ain't on the
same page it don't work and like I said
like I learned a lot about the business
and what to what to use and what to not
use you know what I'm saying yeah I
think sometimes like when you're an
artist and you're on a major label you
have a team
like and all you're doing is worrying
about the creative part sometimes [ __ ]
gets kind of like like falls through the
cracks whether it's like features
whether it's like you know certain
communication with other people's camps
because I always hear that show would be
like yo I was in the studio with
so-and-so
and now now his now his label ain't
clearing the record like and it's like
yo sometimes like that it really ain't
got [ __ ] to do with the artist uh bro
like you know what I'm saying this be
weird bro